hey everyone it's Mike from Immortal
flows and welcome to today's video you
know today is a Thursday January 12 2023
and uh you know this was a day a lot of
people sort of had circled on their
calendar it was CPI day and you know
there was a one month uh 0.1 dip in CPI
and you know a lot of people are
starting to say well look inflation is
cooling off however the core was up 0.3
percent which annualizes out to uh more
or less about four percent which is
still about double the fed's two percent
Target so I don't know you know we've
got the Dollar's been weakening we got
budget deficits consumer credit is off
the charts basically it's soaring you
know everyone says oh consumer spending
numbers were good in you know November
December well yeah it's because the
price of everything else is is going up
so people got to spend more and of
course you know we still have inflation
I don't know why they say oh inflation
is low I go to the grocery store I see
stuff it it ain't up five percent
through ten percent it's a lot of this
stuff is up 20 25
and higher so you know inflation is here
to say you know even though we got a
little bit of a dip in inflation it's
just like a nothing right basically so
but anyway that said you know if you
remember last month the CPI came out you
know there was all this talk about the
number being leaked and you know sort of
coming into the number this morning you
know very tight range as to be expected
anytime you got such a a big number
that's going to affect the market you
know we basically had this range between
you know 95 and three quarters to uh 85
so you know more or less a you know 11
Point range just slightly above it but
as we were getting closer to the number
you saw the market start to Rally
and I think you know on the back of some
Traders minds they're thinking oh you
know last month
um
the signs were there that the number was
leaked you know even though the
government oh no you know there's no
leaks ever in the government yeah which
is
um you know uh you could take that for
what it's worth but you saw the market
basically you know Rally from this you
know 96 and a quarter all the way up to
right before the number I mean I'm not
gonna look there but
um you know 725 it got you know it was
almost a 10-point rally okay which is
what the whole range was coming into
that morning but honestly I think that
if you were sort of trying to play that
oh this number's been leaked
um
you got your head handed to you
obviously the number came out Market
spiked up Got Away up to 19 three
quarters and immediately uh sold off
down two new lows very low low sharp low
54. then what was interesting is
relatively soon we traded back up to new
highs actually at 21 and a half and
surprisingly we came back down after the
cash opened back near our lows and then
what happened later in the day
um you know we sort I don't want to say
we went sideways because you know this
is a big sideways move but you know
relative to that volatility we had
earlier
um
you know it looks sideways you know but
still you know you're still talking 77
up to you know O3 that's
you know what what is that 25 Point
range if you will but that is it started
coming back up towards the High
um late in the day we didn't uh quite
take out that High I mean that high was
21.5 we did get back up to the 18 17 18
level and uh right now you know we're
trading around what is that 07 I think
we you know we spent a lot of time
around the 04-ish area here and we're
sort of poking our head back up now what
was interesting in the order flow is you
know a few things so this is my normal
footprint 30 second chart okay on days
like today you know I know there's going
to be volatility trying to watch a one
minute chart is it's going to give me
extra
stress because the market you know
you're going to have big movements I
like to sort of go down to for me it's a
little bit easier to read the order flow
on a quicker time frame I use a 30
second chart
um
on the e-minis so
obviously you're not going to really
you're not going to want to get involved
around when the number comes out
specifically because of how today
reacted I mean I've been trading around
numbers since you know the 1990s so you
know what is that 30 years and I I've
seen this happen over and over
you know usually you would see it on
non-farm payrolls I remember the time
when CPI was just like nothing you know
we got CPI today oh okay let's go have
breakfast but now it's like you know CPI
is is the big thing but you're seeing
right the nice movements that you're
getting even on the 30 second chart
right 87 down to 75 you know so even on
a 30 second chart you're getting 12
points of movement now this is just a
normal footprint and on days where
you're going to have a lot of volatility
looking at a normal footprint in my
opinion is yeah
not going to be very effective I mean
you can right if you know what to look
for I like to simplify things that's why
I like to use things like the value
areas of the bar you know where 70 of
the volume trades right value areas is
sort of a carryover from volume profile
and Market profile
um just because it gives me an idea of
you know is the market balancing or is
it running basically you know is it I
don't say out of balance but is it
making a move and for me the easiest way
to see that is with value areas and you
know on our software
and actually now you know since we put
this on our software a year ago over a
year ago I'm starting to see other order
flow software add this in so
you just scroll down here if you're
using my software the Overflow is Trader
software
um enable value area you know I like to
use it until tested and we also got the
engulfing value area which is a slightly
more powerful
value area okay it sort of carries over
from the Candlestick you know engulfing
value areas but I actually have one open
on my other tab right here okay so let's
just sort of go back and again you know
trying to analyze the order flow when a
number comes out you can't uh in all
honesty honestly some people well you
put a buy stop here and a sell stop here
and this and that you're not right
because you can see the liquidity in
here all right you put a sell stop in
here I don't know call it o4 right
you're not gonna get filled until it
trades down into the 80s down here even
that there's just no volume going
through it's just an algo probably just
ran right through the order book you
don't see anybody buying you don't see
any counter trades going on and this
happened just like that you know super
fast
um then obviously we found that low so
again you know you got to have a big
number come out everyone is waiting for
the CPI you know even I was talking
about it that's and I don't really get
too excited about numbers but you got to
keep sort of your your eye on when you
have numbers coming out but once the
market settles down you know I like to
give it minimum of five minutes but on
big numbers non-farm payrolls fed
um I like to give those you know
slightly more time about 15 minutes or
so so you know even though I'm looking
at the market I'm not really looking to
get involved a little bit later so you
know this is the 745 area in here we
sort of calmed down a bit right after
this initial
buying and selling burst going through
so
what I'm waiting for now is you know
because it puts us around 7 45 you know
any sort of trend developments you know
one way or the other because now the
markets had time to really digest the
number and everybody's like okay this is
what I want to do now today again you
know if you're watching the chart it was
it went
it didn't just
um make a move up but then it made the
move down pull back made a move down
again you know honestly I'm surprised we
didn't take out that low of the day over
here that was made during the number but
let's take a look you know what could
you have seen in the order flow on this
move up this move down this move back
down and then possibly this will back up
and that's why I like to use you know
sort of the the newer more advanced
methods and I'll say it's an advanced
method but it's one of the the ways that
I use order flow and I've been teaching
to Traders is looking at the the value
areas now the Advent of you know my
newest version of order flows Trader we
actually will color in the value areas
of the bar if it's a green up candle
it's a green value area if it's a red
down candle it's a red value area or if
it's a doji candle meaning it opened and
closed at the same price it'll be gray
okay but really what I'm looking for is
combination of two things
I'm looking for
an area well actually three things I'm
looking for an area where you got a lot
of overlapping value here you got five
bars where these value areas are
overlapping that's telling me there's
balance being formed
next thing I'm looking for is a gap in
value either to the upside or to the
downside I have this big gap in value
from this is the value area high of this
bar it's at 95 and a quarter then the
next bar the value area low is 97 and a
quarter so about two point gap between
the valuers it's not a gap between the
bars it's a gap between the value areas
and the third thing I'm looking for is
this value area this virgin value area
if you will this area that hasn't been
retraced back into in this bar
to kick off right so now I'm drawing out
I'm extending out the value area that's
what this green area is I'm extending it
out
until it gets tested again because or in
other words gets retraced back into
that's why you don't see a a green
Zone coming out of this bar this bar
because the next bar is traded right
back into it here's another one up here
it came right back into it but I know
that once I have sort of these three
things I got a balance area then I got a
gap in value and I've got that naked or
virgin or whatever you want to call it
value area that hasn't been traded back
into to me that's a very strong signal
it's a ghost signal right and of course
you got to wait till this bar closes
because one you're not going to know
that this value area gapped it's not
going to be confirmed until this bar
here closes because obviously if this
bar is still trading if you trade right
back in there then you're not going to
have a gap
because the value area of this bar
theoretically can trade back into the
value of this bar so again you're not
going to know until it closes that you
also have this value area that's been
hasn't been retested okay so once this
bar closes then you're off to the races
right then you can be getting long 4000
area
okay and it's shot right all the way up
to you know to 10 here then you see on
the way up you got another value area
that's being abandoned
um so you got
one here this is the one that triggers
Your your long then you got another one
coming in here
um you know you trade all the way up
here so again you know
if you're trying to buy
you know add on you know you're long
already from double low maybe you could
have thought of adding in you know after
you see this bar but again you know if
you add it in here it pulls back down to
where the area where you had that value
and then what happens it goes sideways
okay but really this is the trigger
right here right based on those three
three things all right so then the
market starts going higher okay now
again at this time it's eight o'clock
okay so we got 30 minutes before the
cash opened
um
we get up in here and we have this red
down candle right we've got the red
value area kicking off in here now
it's a naked
value area right but you don't have a
gap right it comes this Bar's value area
high comes right up to the value area
low and you don't necessarily have a lot
of this
you know the overlapping right you got
these two bars overlapping and that's it
right over here you had one two three
four five okay so yeah it's not as nice
to see not as strong and you get another
bullish one here
but again what do you get right
you got the Gap but one two three value
areas that overlapping now you're coming
up near the high again you could buy it
again there's nothing wrong with buying
a high I just prefer to look for reason
to get short off a high
and you know you're buying into this
High you know maybe you're buying around
19 it only gets up to 21 and a half and
it comes back down now
the thing with value areas and
especially if it's value areas that are
you know coming out of a balanced area
like this one
you know I'm always looking for these
value areas these ones that are being
drawn out you know these untested value
areas as a support or resistance right
just like here right you have this big
value area from when the number came out
basically between 09 and 14
and you can see the market rallied back
up to this value where it got a little
bit above it and it's just acting as
this resistance right you got this one
here it's acting as resistance over one
two three four
five bars and eventually you pop up okay
now on this way down
again now we're sort of coming into that
that time before the cash open where you
got to be careful because obviously once
the cash opens
whatever was bullish could become
bearish you know the order flow can is
going to flip on you really quick so
let's just you know take a look right
obviously you got the abandoned value
area here this one was nice right you
have
this move down then you're sort of
overlapping one you know one two three
four five six bars and again even though
it's just by one tick to me that's still
overlapping then you get the Gap here
right and you got your value area being
abandoned here and this is a nice move
but again I I me personally I sort of
shy away from taking trades right ahead
of the cash open unless I think it's
going to be a quick trade and I can be
out once the cash opens so once the cash
opens the price movement's going to
really pick up and and get going but but
still this was a decent trade it's a 13
you know
and it's a move from around you know I
don't know what the 4 000 Point again
you know down to the 90s right in here
um so anyway so the cash opens
okay and what do you see right off the
bat
you see the selling coming in
you've got
value area value area value area value
value right so you got one two three
four five six seven that are overlapping
and this last one by just by its by a
hair by one tick and you got that
naked value area
what do you think the trade is doing
then you get the Gap here right so once
this bar closes it's 8 32 and 30 second
bar
you should be thinking short all the way
and boom it breaks down from you know
the 39.90 area all the way down I mean
it it was just it was like a snowball
going down down down down down to the
64s areas and even on the way you're
seeing you know anything bullish coming
in yeah I mean you got this one value
area this one Gap here
right this abandoned value area this
naked value area here but doesn't really
go anywhere right I mean this would be
the bar that you'd wait you're waiting
for it to close to decide whether you're
getting long or not but it's coming
right into an area where you've got this
event this value where you know this
resistance area so even if you're
looking to get long you're getting long
into resistance right and remember this
Market had been kicking off a lot of
resistance here here here now
right so trying to buy into resistance
isn't always the greatest trade idea and
then what happens the market just keeps
on going down right even here you've got
one two three four a little balance area
here
you got the value area of being extended
out right it hasn't been retraced to in
the next Mark out within one tick then
you got the Gap in the value area you
should still be thinking short
and the market just you know kept moving
down down and again there were
some potential signs of a potential long
in here right you've got this
um this bar here at 851 right and value
areas overlapped one two three bars and
it gaps up you have this
value area being extended out okay
possibly
then you wait for the next bar to come
in
and doesn't even go any higher than than
this then this bar right I sort of one
of the the signs that
there's actually some signs here in this
bar in the order flow that it wasn't
going to go up at least in the next bar
or two is the fact that it's closing you
know off its high right generally you
know these bars
when you're looking for order flow or
anything even candlesticks right if
you're just watching price action
obviously the bar that goes up and then
sort of closes down and it's midpoint is
a weak bullish bar at best if anything
it's like to me it's more slanted more
towards
um
slightly bearish okay
um then it finally Finds Its low here
around 854 and then it starts making its
move back up and as it starts making its
move back up again you're seeing some
nice bullish value areas but then it
comes down here as bearish right you got
that value area that's being abandoned
right here then it comes down into this
little Dippy area okay but what do you
got you got one two three value areas
that are overlapping then you got that
big gap here again you're sort of
running into
your resistance here right the zone
so you still got it you gotta wait right
you're not gonna just go ahead and pull
that trigger right what you're going to
want to see is obviously this Bar's got
to close but this bar right you want to
see it
start moving a bit higher and it's up as
a doji candle it opens and closes at the
same price so okay let's wait for the
next bar right and then it's off to the
races again you know boom over the next
several bars your rallies about you know
over 10 10 to 15 points but look at this
here okay
you got one two three bars overlapping
the value areas and the value area lows
are slightly moving higher you got that
Gap
but this bar here it's trades one tick
above but it's hanging around the high
of this bar okay as opposed to this low
here
right you got the one two three value
areas and then this bar is starting to
go up but then it closes back down and
then this bar doesn't even go any higher
so comparing this order flow
to this order flow here
you know it's very similar in the sense
of the one two three Gap and the value
area but the difference is this bar
right we're hanging we're still hanging
around the high now this bar we close up
right near our high of the of the bar
right we didn't come back off halfway
down
and then the next bar open up we're
still holding that price movement right
that price action higher so you'd be
looking for this Market to potentially
go up right as opposed to down here
all right where it went up and then the
same bar it closed down at its midpoint
and the next Bar opens up down there and
then trades lower
so
you know after that order flow here
right then it was just it was just right
back up right we got all the way back up
from you know the the 39 84 85 area all
the way back above 4 000.
so anyway I don't want to keep this
video going on much longer because it's
pushing 20 minutes but I hope you guys
understand right the importance of
looking at things such as the value
areas in the order flow and again I've
been teaching this for
over a year going back to 20 21 and I'm
just starting to see it in more and more
order flow software which I guess is a
good thing you know people sometimes ask
me oh did you see what so-and-so is
doing with their order flow footprint
you know they're adding what you got I'm
like yeah I mean okay you know I mean
it's just a way to read the market right
you know people oh you should have some
copyright or something no you know it's
all about
um formatting the data into an easy to
read form yeah do I wish that people
would give me a credit for it but yeah I
mean like say oh you know I got this
from Mike but um
yeah it's just one of those things where
keep it simple you don't need fancy
indicators even though I got a lot of
indicators that read order flow for you
you know sometimes if you just keep it
simple understanding where value is
understanding where markets balance it's
just going to help you become a better
Trader right by understanding what is
happening in the market rather than
reacting to what's happening right you
can react to it once you understand it
it makes it much more easier to trade so
have a great day everybody and I'll
catch you guys on the next video bye bye